toi eu un geste pratiquer au quotidien
mais qui ici prend une toute autre
tournure au fil des round le nombre de
bouteilles a débouché le plus vite
possible va crescendo pour ces athlètes
venus des quatre coins de la france
l'épreuve sévèrement plus visible au
prévenu
puis c'est même très difficile c'est la
première fois que je fais ça je comptais
faire mieux mais bon j'ai cassé la
plupart des bouchons ici on ne rigole
pas championnat du monde oblige hommes
comme femmes doivent se confronter à des
règles très strictes
quatre juges arbitres reneaume sont là
pour les faire respecter à la virgule
près
il a aggravé des bûchers
avec c'est un méchant indom le bouchon
qui en possèdent un habitat ces
éliminatoires
mougenot bouteilles cassées et une à
thouars der heide qui peuvent coûter
très cher et même aux plus confirmés
lille champion en titre non c'est
désormais quelque chose
c'est lamentable
les bouchons un pur mensonge
le champion se faire éliminer comme
eto'o comme ça c
ujourd'hui pas assez par affiné les
bouchons deviennent vite le centre de
toutes les conversations
une polémique qui n'attend pas pour
autant le moral du public
c'est intéressant ça fait de l'animation
dans le village s'amène et du monde mois
les championnes du monde et les
touristes qui viennent c'est désagréable
après trois heures de compétition et
plus de 1000 bouteilles débouchées ce
sont finalement deux locaux qui
s'imposent avec à la clé du musée rien
qu'au début j'ai évidemment
m
[Musique]